you start with this circle right and
they give you some information that's on
the diagram but not very much
and then the rest of it's verbal so the
first thing i did you can actually see
it on my working here
the first thing i did was to try and
combine those two together so you've got
this uh
chord that's been um divided off i think
that's a b
right yeah yep um you've got the center
of the circle o
and then the rest of information is
provided verbally so they say a b
is a chord of length six through three
centimeters so that's me
putting that in right there is that okay
what's the other piece of information
they need to put on the diagram
i've got the radius right so it's going
to be here and
here they're both going to be six
and i know i need both because what's
the question actually asking what's
what do they want they want okay we're
gonna get to an area but before that
before that they want an angle namely
this guy here now think to your
trigonometry decision tree right what
are you going to use
what and speak of the devil and she
shall appear
i literally just said the words
trigonometry decision tree
okay i heard it's the bat signal okay
have a look
have a look you got three sides here in
an angle what is it
cosine rule right
so i'm going to write cos of aob
right now you have the cosine rule on
your reference sheet right
this is the one where you've got a
fraction on the right hand side
so i'm going to start to put in the
pieces right there's going to be an
a squared plus b squared
minus c squared divided by what
two a b now
this is an important point please have a
look up at my working and i'll just rub
off the rest of this stuff because
unnecessary
as um as was highlighted when we first
looked at the trigonometry decision tree
right
the important thing with the cosine rule
is that you know which side is which a b
and c
are different because you do different
things to them
how did i know that this is the c and
not
like one of these other ones um
yeah very good it's opposite right now
uh you'll definitely get marks for
working but depends on what kind of
working you've got
okay now i'm going to teach you a little
sneaky thing
that comes up a lot it's a it's kind of
something i didn't realize until i
started teaching it right
you're going to use the cosine rule in
circles just like this quite a bit
i want you to watch really carefully
what i'm about to do so just pens out of
hands and
have a look one of the instincts that
you will have and i will
put money on the table the 90 of you if
you got this far you will do this on the
next line
you'll just start expanding stuff right
you'll be like 36
36 whatever on earth that is 2 times 36
and then off you go
your numbers get big you start canceling
stuff fingers crossed
but i want you to look closer there's
something you can do that makes this
faster and easier you never need to
touch a calculator watch this
see there's a six squared there and
there's also a six squared there
and there's hiding a six
squared there and there's one last six
squared down here
do you notice that now this actually
always happens in circles because of
this
radius business right so i can just
cancel six squared from the top
and from the bottom watch closely this
is what i end up with
that becomes a one that becomes a one
this guy here becomes minus root three
squared root three squared is just three
and then i cancel the last six squared
down the bottom
look ma no calculator right two minus
three that's
negative a half okay so i've got
cos of aob now i'm not quite finished
yet
okay ashana come to your question in a
second i'm just mindful the time
now i'm going to teach you i'm going to
teach you another trick can you reach
your calculator there
okay
now we discussed this exact idea
yesterday i know a lot of you
feel comfortable in degrees you feel
comfortable in degrees
and you do a lot of work in degrees
before you go to radians
okay by the way why am i talking about
this why do i know i need to do radians
have a look at the questions the
question tells me right i read the
question
shh you're 12.
show me you've got your calculator in
hand but i need your eyes up so that i
know i have your attention thanks very
much appreciate it okay
watch carefully here's how we're going
to do this i don't know if we'll work on
yours tyler like
it depends on what the calculator is
okay make sure you're in radians mode
we're strong on time i want to use it
well
make sure in your radian mode right and
then
this is cos of an angle we actually just
want the angle
right so what you're going to need to do
is say shift
cos and then you're going to put in
negative a half or negative 0.5
okay now once you do that predictably it
will throw you back
some decimal garbage right because
you're like what is that
now why is there so much decimal stuff
in here and the answer is we're talking
in radians
so there's a pie hiding in this right
it's like maybe it's pi
on two or maybe it's like pi on four or
something like that
right now if there's going to be a pie
hiding there
there's an easy way to get rid of the
pie which is on your calculator with the
answer still there
please go and press divide
by pi now if you do that
i hope you recognize the decimal that's
staring back at you or press the
fraction button if you don't
it's telling you two-thirds but that's
because you divided by pi
so if you put the pi back there's your
angle does that make sense
now some of you of course will be like i
prefer degrees if you did this in degree
mode it'll tell you 120 degrees
and then you can convert back but like
when the calculator can do it for you
why wouldn't you
does that make sense okay